what gives people power money
status well they might give some people
power
but what gives all of us power is our
mitochondria
referred to as the powerhouse of the
cell the mitochondria is involved in
aerobic respiration
that generates energy for the cell it
really is
a fascinating organelle and it also
contains
its own dna this is really interesting
to understand
but one of the problems associated with
this is like
the nuclear dna mitochondrial dna can
also get mutated
and this can lead to disease
understanding these diseases
and just the mitochondria in general
would be greatly aided
if we could manipulate the gene so that
you could study the mitochondria
but to do this you would need a tool
that would enable you to easily edit
the genes this recent nature paper
may have uncovered a unique way of
editing mitochondrial genes so hello and
welcome to the cheeky science show
where in this video we'll talk about
this paper and explore
how you can actually try and modify
genes within the mitochondria
so firstly we'll talk about gene editing
in general
and about the key factors you want in a
good gene editing tool
we'll then talk about the development of
this tool in terms of the mitochondria
and we'll look at some of its strengths
and some of its weaknesses and then also
some of the potential applications of
this tool
and areas of further study to further
optimize the tool
and to also discuss where it could go in
the future
so let's get to it if you are interested
in understanding gene editing
likelihood is you've heard of the term
crispr
usually referring to the crispr cast 9
system
crispr is a system that can edit dna by
introducing
a double-stranded break and enabling the
cell to undergo repair mechanisms
whereby it can result in insertional
deletions
into the site or if introduced with
a double-stranded dna template or a
single strand
dna template that contains desired
changes of interest and this is referred
to as
precise genome editing and so either is
used depending on the application
and so there are two kind of criteria
that are important for developing
a genome editing technique the first
criteria is that you want it to be safe
and secondly you want it to be efficient
double strum brakes are notoriously
unsafe
for a cell and so there's been much
optimization to crispr cast 9 systems to
try
and improve the safety and also the
efficiency to go along with it
and that has resulted most recently in
the development of prime editing
but to be able to modify mitochondrial
dna
an alternative strategy was required and
this is because
crispr cas9 systems depend on and
guide rna that targets the crispr cast 9
complex
to specific regions of dna but getting
the
rna into mitochondria is pretty
unfeasible
for a cell secondly the mitochondria
lacks efficient mechanisms to
be able to repair double strand dna
breaks
and this is another reason why crispr
would be ineffective for editing
mitochondrial dna
however crispr isn't the only gene
editing system
before crispr there were talents and
sink finger nucleases similarly to
crispr cast 9
these two different editing techniques
also induce double-stranded breaks
however the key difference is that
crispr cas9
directed the complex by a guide rna
zinc finger nucleases and tolerance
required protein dna interactions
so this circumvents the issue of not
being able to get rna into the
mitochondria
because the protein dna interaction can
be used instead
however as i just said these techniques
also
induce double stranded breaks for their
gene editing
which as i've already mentioned
mitochondria don't really have
any mechanisms to repair double-stranded
breaks
so the question is then how can you
actually edit
without double-stranded breaks well the
solution to this problem
was base editing which was devised by
david leo's lab
who unsurprisingly are also behind this
recent paper
so base editing is a geoname editing
method that efficiently converts one
base pair
to a different base pair so dna contains
two base pairs you have cytosine
paired with guanine so c to g and
adenine
paired with thymine so a to t so base
editing therefore would change a c to g
base pair
to an a to t base pair or vice versa so
there are currently
two different classes of base editors
adenine based editors
or cytosine based editors and so
cytosine base editors
work by having a cytadine deaminase
which
removes an amine grape from cytosine
which converts
cytosine into uracil so although uracil
has the same base pairing properties
as thymine so it pairs with adenine it
belongs on rna not dna
so the uracil base is normally cut from
dna with the help of an enzyme
called uracil dna glycosylase
and then it's replaced with cytosine
however instead of going back to
cytosine instead we want it to be red as
thymine
so to do this in base editing the
complex is also fused with a uracil
glycosylase inhibitor
which protects the uracil from the
glycosylase until the next round of dna
replication
at which point the base from the
complementary strand
so the guanine that was part of the c
before editing
is then replaced with adenine and then
you get
the change from c to g to t to a
so this is one way you can edit dna
precisely
without a double stranded break however
current based editing applications
use the crispr cast system to guide
the base editing complex to the correct
site
on dna which we know already
is ineffective for mitochondrial editing
because of the issue of getting rna into
the mitochondrial
and just to make things even worse
current based editors
deaminate the nucleotides in single
stranded dna loops that are created by
these rna-guided crispr proteins
so instead a deaminase was required
that could actually recognize
double-stranded dna
so this is one of the reasons why trying
to edit the mitochondrial dna
has so far been considered a big
challenge
david leo's group were exploring
different
diamonases the entire super family of
diamonds
and they were exploring their
biochemical activity
and they came across one deaminase
that actually uh converted cytosine to
uracil within double stranded dna
which was super exciting and they made
the
cool connection with the this ability
and the chance of potentially now
editing mitochondrial dna
and the name of this enzyme was coined
double-stranded dna d-aminase toxin a
or ddda for short
or triple d a if you want to be cool
maybe that's just me
so taking this triple d a and fusing it
with the tallinn system
so that's fusing it to these tail repeat
arrays that recognize specific
dna sequences in addition to also adding
this uracil dna glycosylase inhibitor
the team were on to developing a
crispr-free mitochondrial base editing
system however as hinted
in triple da's name toxin
adding this full triple da
protein into human cell cell lines
was actually toxic for the cells so to
circumvent this
the team designed a way to split up the
sequence
of triple da into two halves an
n-terminal half
and a c-terminal half and fused them
separately
to different tail arrays along with
these
uracil dna glycosalase inhibitors so
i've cut a very long and probably very
arduous
story very short because there's many
different ways that you can manipulate
the system
in terms of modifying it so what i mean
by that is
we know that we've now split up this one
protein into an n-terminal half and a
two-term and a half
and fuse them separately and in terms of
the system working
there's going to be differences in
whereabouts she splits
the protein in terms of the efficiency
of the editing
but there are many more variables
besides just that
also the spacing between the two base
editors subunits
also will have an impact as well as the
orientation
of the split halves and the position of
the
target cytosine relative to the
tail binding sites and that's something
i think i have failed to mention so far
this triple d a is a cytodine the amines
and it actually has a strong preference
for
tc contacts so that would be having the
thymine before the cytosine
residue that then gets converted to
uracil
and so depending on the space between
the two halves of these
editing subunits there could be more
than one site that potentially could get
modified
so let's go back to our two criteria
safety and efficiency
so firstly because the system doesn't
induce double strand breaks
but no breaks at all then in addition to
the fact that by splitting up
triple d a we reduce the toxicities to
the cells
the system can be considered fairly safe
although we'll come back to this a
little bit later
however what about deficiency well this
was also tested by the team
and was promising they saw a variety of
different efficiency levels
mainly due to the different variables as
i've already listed
but they saw efficiency levels range
from
4.6 up to 49
and so that's pretty good considering
that the theoretical
maximum would be around 50 because the
editing conversion depends on this
uracil being changed to thymine during
dna replication
and there's a 50 50 chance that it would
go the other way
hence the 50 percent but actually having
a variety of different
editing efficiencies could actually also
be a very useful thing regarding this
tool
and that's because unlike the fact that
we have
just you know our one nucleus containing
nuclear dna there's lots of different
mitochondria
within a cell and so there's more than
one copy of mitochondrial dna
and interestingly a lot of these
diseases in
mitochondrial dna that i've spoken about
can
have different phenotypes depending on
what percentage of the mitochondria
contain that same mutation
and so this is given a kind of cool name
heteroplasmy
so to quote from this news and fuse
article about this
this paper a mixture of low and high
efficiency triple d
a cytosine based editors will be useful
for creating a range of heteroplasmy
levels
to investigate the minimum threshold for
phenotype change and clinical penetrance
of known and newly reported
mitochondrial dna mutations so going
back to
safety another key consideration besides
whether or not there's any double strand
breaks
and chance of there being aberrant
modifications
at on-site dna sites
off target editing by triple d
cytosine based editors also needed to be
confirmed
for example it was potentially plausible
that
you could get edits within the nuclear
dna
whilst we're already directing this base
editor to the mitochondria
which is something else i forgot to
mention another component they needed to
add
to the space editor is a mitochondrial
targeting sequence that enables
the complex to get through the double
membrane of the mitochondria very useful
but excitingly they didn't observe
significant of target editing
at nuclear pseudogenes even though some
of them differed
only by one to two base pairs from the
mitochondrial dna
on target sites and so that
to some extent could be explained by the
high targeting efficiency
of having this mitochondrial targeting
sequence
suggesting that none of the complex is
really reaching the nucleus
and that's kind of backed up by this
figure here where they've
um colored the mitochondria using a
mighty tracker
and also tagged the base editing complex
and by merging the two layers together
we can see that there's quite a high
overlap
suggesting that it is reaching the
mitochondria as opposed to
other areas of the cell so it seems
pretty safe
we don't really mind too much about
having different levels of efficiency
what applications of this tool are there
well one of the main areas of interest
would be to try and study the phenotype
of different mitochondrial mutations
that
can cause disease as as you can see in
this figure there's quite a lot of them
and this technique is also cool and the
fact that it has the potential to edit
post mitotic cells so these are cells
that won't undergo cell division
because the repair process depends only
on mitochondrial replication
which happens more frequently and while
it still occurs in cells that don't
divide themselves
so besides that it would also be
interesting just to further understand
mitochondrial biology and also to
potentially
test different treatments along with the
mutations but
given this tool so far as we know it
works on double-stranded
dna it could be applied to other
areas so it could also be tried in
nuclear dna or other organelles such as
chloroplasts
so i think yeah there's lots of
different exciting applications of this
tool
and it'll be interesting to see how many
studies taken on
however it goes without saying there are
still areas of improvement such as
trying to
further increase the efficiency and
maybe seeing if they can edit
um cytosine residues that aren't just
preceded by
thymine and if it was ever going to be
used in treatments
and developing a way to actually get
this system
into a cell so delivery of the system is
also something that would need to be
worked on
but that's kind of goes without saying
for any of these
gene editing systems at the moment so
hopefully you now
understand how this crisper free
rna-free base editor works
so hopefully you have learned something
and as always
thanks for listening